welcome back to New rockstars I'm
Jessica Clemons the Mortal Kombat
franchise has been smashing faces and
ripping spines since 92 and has
accumulated a very dense and impressive
lore filled with power struggles Elder
gods and a healthy splatter of time
travel the standard edition of Mortal
Kombat 1 launched is September 19th on
PS5 Xbox series SX PC and Nintendo
switch thank you WB Games for sponsoring
this video click the link in the
description below for more information
we're going to do a breakdown of every
playable character that's been announced
from the fan favorites to the insane
special guest to the deep cut combatants
making their triumphant return by
telling their stories we'll catch you up
on how far this franchise has come since
devouring literally every quarter I had
in the 90s and I had only two remember
new rockstars is three channels so make
sure you're subscribed to the break room
and the Deep dive for more pop culture
analysis then you can shake a recently
ripped Spy Net oh no okay let's go on
the best place to start giving you the
idea of what's going on in Mortal Kombat
1 is with Liu Kang he's arguably the
main character of the series being one
of the only ones who's appeared in every
generation of the game he's one of the
humans fighting to prevent a war without
World a fantasy Dimension filled with
Monsters Magic and a constant royal
power struggle at the end of Mortal
Kombat 11 the Thunder God Raiden merged
his Essence with Liu Kang turning him
into a fire god using his new powers he
creates his own timeline which is where
Mortal Kombat 1 takes place in the
announcement trailer we see that some of
the old Mortal Kombat backstories and
relationships are in place but others
have been flipped or altered for
instance Sub-Zero and Scorpion who have
been Rivals for most of the series are
fighting alongside each other this is
just one of the many changes that has
Mortal Kombat lore nerds digging for
every Easter egg they can find Liu Kang
was always a heroic character but what
kind of deity will he be the
announcement trailer ends on a brutally
ambiguous note with Liu Kang saying you
have chosen war with a God and then
absolutely annihilating an enemy with a
dialed up to 11 version of his Dragon
fatality we first saw in Mortal Kombat
2. Johnny Cage arguably one of my most
hated characters was an arrogant
Hollywood actor turned Mortal Kombat who
learned that he was a descendant from a
warrior cult that could use green intent
in Magic he was originally modeled after
Jean-Claude Van Damme as is evidenced by
his flashy style and willingness to do
the splits at any possible opportunity
God I hate this man I love and hate him
Mortal Kombat Creator Ed Boone
originally wanted Van Damme to do the
mocap for cage in the original game but
he was unavailable things have come back
around in Mortal Kombat 1 because you
can play as Van Damme's version of
Johnny Cage thanks to a downloadable
character skin in the new game you could
actually fight inside his Mansion
complete with the infinity pool so gaudy
I hate and love him in this new reality
cage no longer has his green energy
attacks could it be that the this
version wasn't descended from Magic
users or maybe he just hasn't unlocked
his powers yet this is a really cool
example of how the story of Mortal
Kombat 1 is woven into the gameplay
speaking of actors it was recently
announced that Megan Fox will be voicing
the returning character natara she's a
vampire character who originally
appeared in Mortal Kombat Deadly
Alliance she's been an interesting
character because she's neither good nor
evil but rather a neutral party looking
to create her own realm her name means
deeply rooted standing firm in Indian
we're not sure what this version of the
character's motivations are but it does
appear her love of blood is still intact
and I think it's like fun casting Fox as
his character hopefully people remember
her criminally underrated role as a
demonic high school cheerleader in
Jennifer's Body because I do another
returning fan favorite and my fan
favorite is Sub-Zero the mantle of
Sub-Zero is actually one that's passed
on to various members of the linquay
Assassins the first Sub-Zero was bihan
who would go on to be Noob Saibot a
shadow ninja whose name backwards is
Tobias Boone the last name of the
creators of the franchise in this new
timeline bihan is Sub-Zero and the Grand
Master of the Lynn Queen way his story
trailer sees him leading a force of
ninjas on a raid on what could be a
Shaolin Temple fighting alongside him a
scorpion who had been his rival in the
previous games and speaking of which
second favorite character with arguably
the biggest lore change in Mortal Kombat
1 is Scorpion who has been confirmed to
be a Lin Kwai assassin known as Qui
Liang in past game scorpion has been a
resurrected ninja named Hanzo hashashi
who wanted revenge on Sub-Zero for the
death of his family Hui Liang the
current scorpion was the second Sub-Zero
after bihan in the Mortal Kombat 2. it
will be fascinating to see how this new
Dynamic plays out in the story we do
know that scorpion will have the
trademark catchphrase get over here that
was really good of me cast me next time
which was voiced by series Creator Ed
Boon in the original game if the
Scorpion is quiet Liang where is Hanzo
hasashi is this one of the other ninjas
trapped in the Multiverse somewhere
something tells me that he'll eventually
pop up in this new timeline in that
story trailer Sub-Zero and Scorpion are
seen fighting alongside smoke he was a
hidden character in Mortal Kombat 2
turned into a robot in Mortal Kombat 3
and brought back in human form for
Mortal Kombat at 2011 though it's
revealed in his ending that he's
actually a demonic creature made of
vapor he appears to be human here with
the Nifty new knife skills we see the
ninjas fighting Kung Lao and Rain a
purple ninja who was originally kind of
a gag character in Ultimate Mortal
Kombat 3. he's purple his name's rain no
I will not be singing any Prince hits no
matter how many times you ask in the
comments or maybe I will just try his
backstory fleshed out in future games
and make him the son of the demi-god
fighting for the throne of outworld he
appears to be a magic user fighting
alongside Kung Lao in the trailer the
last ninja in the original character
lineup is reptile originally an
unplayable secret character in the first
game he became playable in Mortal Kombat
2. in this game he can shapeshift from
Human to lizard form for some
devastating special moves he looks to be
fighting alongside Johnny Cage and some
other human characters which would be a
flip on his usual role as an antagonist
Katana was originally the daughter of
Mortal Kombat 2 big bad Shao Khan she
was revealed to be their heir to the
throne of a world called adenia that was
conquered and subsumed by outworld in
Mortal Kombat 1 she's an um Gotti a
warrior Priestess and the protector her
sister Molina Molina is the princess of
the still peaceful and not conquered
adenya but their father has been
murdered this will probably be the
inciting event of the plot that turns
Liu Kang's peaceful realm into one where
people are gouging each other's eyes and
removing their bones from their bodies
speaking of Molina she's got a new
backstory of her hone in the original
game she was katana's Sister revealed to
be a clone made with tarkatan DNA
tarkcons were a war like people who have
also undergone a lore change that we'll
talk about in a minute her dual DNA
explained why when she removed her mask
she had a creepy monster face that ate
people and Mortal Kombat 1 she's an heir
to the throne but she's trying to hide
an Affliction the tarkans are no longer
a species but people Afflicted with
tarkat a kind of Rage disease and Molina
is slowly succumbing to it another
member of the umgadi is Tanya a formerly
villainous character introduced in
Mortal Kombat 4. she looks to be high up
in the mgati but given her history as a
villain there might be some double
crossing in her future another character
with ties to them Gotti is Lee May a
deeper cut character who made her debut
and Mortal Kombat Deadly Alliance she's
now the former leader of the umgadi who
left after Molina and katana's father
was murdered in one trailer we see her
trying to talk her way out of a fight
with Tanya and some of the other ugati
Warriors the most prominent pure Tarkan
in Mortal Kombat history is Baraka in
the original game he was a servant of
Shao Khan in Mortal Kombat 1 now the
tarkans are people inflicted with the
disease he leads a group of dissidents
who have been exiled this is an
interesting detail because it points to
the fact that Luke Kang's attempt at a
Utopia also has class struggles and
injustices in the original Mortal Kombat
timeline Raiden was the god of thunder
who led the humans against the Bad
actors of outworld and acted as a kind
of Godly Father Figure to the other
characters in Mortal Kombat he and Liu
Kang have switched roles with Liu Kang
as the omnipotent daddy Raiden is from
the earth realm he's seen tending to a
farm with Kung Lao and training with
kinshi he's noticeably younger than he
was in the other games but still has his
lightning abilities he is chosen by Liu
Kang to represent Earth in the
tournament it's really fun to see these
roles flipped where Raiden is The
Reluctant student now speaking of kenshi
I love kenshi he debuted in Mortal
Kombat Deadly Alliance the blind
swordsman most likely a reference of the
character who is a long-running
character featured in Japanese Samurai
films dating back to the 60s in this
universe he still has his sight will he
lose it by the end of the game given the
amount of eye trauma literally dealt out
in the series I'm guessing it's very
likely in one of the trailers he's
challenging Johnny Cage for a possession
of a sword he calls sento that Johnny
Cage is apparently just using as a wall
decoration very Johnny Cage of him
everyone's favorite future lit spokesman
Kung Lao is back usually seen alongside
Liu Kang like in their spin-off
Adventure Shaolin Monks in this reality
he farms and trains alongside the young
version of Raiden another character from
the deep bench making their return is
Havoc he is a cleric of chaos if there's
any death metal bands out there looking
for a name change I think you just found
it he made his first appearance in
Mortal Kombat deception but hasn't been
a playable character since Mortal Kombat
Armageddon he did however make an
appearance in the Joker's ending in
Mortal Kombat 11 fitting because both he
and the clown Prince of Crime are agents
of chaos and judging by some of the
dialogue from one of the Mortal Kombat 1
trailers Havoc is still a fan his people
can mutilate their own bodies for the
perfect piece of combat you'll notice
that in the battle he cuts off his own
arm and uses it as a weapon in the
trailer he's battling another long Derma
character ashra ashra is another
character who first appeared in Mortal
Kombat deception in that game she's a
human looking character who is actually
a demon from the nether realm who wields
a holy sword called Chris she's still
sporting a blade in Mortal Kombat 1 but
definitely looks more Supernatural in
this game sporting all black guys and I
love her she's beautiful I can't wait to
play as her she's been on both sides of
the hero villain divide but this bit of
dialogue from the trailer suggests that
she's with the good guys this time
around and on topic of good guys versus
bad guys the final boss of Mortal Kombat
2 is back and in the center of courtly
power struggle in Mortal Kombat 1. he's
referred to as general Xiao he still
wrecking shop with his hammer and
clearly has beef with Liu Kang then we
have sindel who was an evil magic user
introduced in Mortal Kombat 3 she now
appears to be playing for the good guys
she's still a mother to Katana Molina
like she was in the original games and
still throws down using her
tentacle-like hair she's also beautiful
I'm obsessed with her Garrus is the only
character in the main roster who first
appeared in the last game in the series
Mortal Kombat 11. he was created by
cronica the big bad of Mortal Kombat 11
to help her preserve the time stream in
this game he's protecting The Hourglass
a mythical object that regulates time he
has memories of the old timelines and is
now working with Liu Kang to protect his
specific vision for reality so it is
possible for characters to remember some
of the destroyed timelines which leads
me to Shang Tsung the boss of the
original game has appeared in both old
and young versions in the series in the
opening cut scene we see him selling
medicine as an old man one of the
diseases he's Hawking cures tarkot the
blight that's affected Molina and Baraka
later the old man's Garb is revealed to
be a costume he uses to see more
trustworthy he is approached by a
mysterious stranger that might be
chronica or her daughter from Mortal
Kombat 11. this stranger offers Shang
Tsung who in this world is a magic-free
grifter access to actual magic which he
seems pretty stoked about so it would
appear that there are characters left
over for Mortal Kombat 11 that still
remember the original timeline could the
story of Mortal Kombat 1 be a struggle
between Liu Kang and the characters from
the past looking to undo their undoing
there might be some clues in the new
Cameo system The Cameo characters are
familiar faces from past Mortal Kombat
games we have Sonya Blade Jax and Kano
but also alternate versions of the
characters in the main roster like
Sub-Zero and Kung Lao these characters
all seem to be in costume from previous
games one theory is that these Cameo
characters have been pulled out of their
original timelines into this game by
chronic or someone else from an erased
reality who's trying to restore the
status quo if you pick up the Premium
Edition which includes the combat Pack 1
you'll get the first wave of DLC
characters this lineup has some truly
insane additions to the roster from past
Mortal Kombat games you have Ermac Quan
Chi and Takeda but you also have
homelander from the boys Omni man from
invincible and mother Flippin Peacemaker
baby oh God it's so beautiful Modern
Combat has always had insane guest
characters like Joker and Jason Voorhees
from other franchises and it's always a
blast see and then throw down with
Mortal kombat's roster well no gameplay
of these characters has been shown Ed
Boon has said that Omni man and
homelander will play differently despite
their similar power sets and I could
only hope peacemaker can call in eagerly
for an assist
so that's a breakdown of everyone you'll
be seeing in the main roster in Mortal
Kombat 1. let us know who you're going
to be maning in the comments because you
know mine's gonna be sindel or Sub-Zero
thank you again to WB Games for
sponsoring this video be sure to click
the link in the description below for
more information you can get over here
follow me at Lulu underscore Clemens
follow any rockstars on all social
platforms be sure to also follow the
break room where every now and then they
play some video games I'll see you guys
later
foreign
[Music]